if you were to ask people in 1983 what
would you like in a personal computer
they would have said bigger faster
cheaper ms-dos machine bigger faster
cheaper Apple - no one would have
described the Macintosh and so the the
genius of Steve Jobs is not that he
listens to the marketplace for focus
groups and marketing research and then
he takes that research and he implements
it he does not believe in market
research market research for Apple
Computer is Steve's left hemisphere is
connected to his right hemisphere that's
the focus group and so the lesson of
Apple is you know you cannot necessarily
just listen to what people are saying
they need because they are going to
define everything they need in terms
they already know bigger faster cheaper
the true revolutionary the truly
enchanting company creates a product or
service before people can really define
the need for that product or service
they have anticipated where the market
will go as opposed to simply reacted
quickly to where the market is already
going